موجه من الخسائر تكبدتها اسهم البنوك
العالميه يوم الجمعه الماضي معا انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي في الولايات المتحده
الذي يعتبر الاكبر منذ الازمه الماليه
العالميه ففي خطوه سريعه لحمايه اموال
المودعين قامت الجهه التنظيميه للقطاع
المصرفي في ولايه كاليفورنيا باغلاق
مجموعه بنك سيليكون فالي اذ حاول
المستثمرون والمودعون سحب 42 مليار دولار
من البنك يوم الخميس الماضي وفقا لافصاح
تنظيمي وفي ختام الاعمال في التاسع من
مارس كان لدى البنك رصيد نقدي سلبي قدره
958 مليون دولار البنك الذي تركز انشطته
على الشركات الناشئه تكبد خسائر قدرها
مليار و800 مليون دولار في بيع سندات
الخزانه الامريكيه والاوراق الماليه
المدعومه بالرهن العقاري وقام بوضع خطه
لجمع مليارين و250 مليون دولار من
وهي شركه ناشئه تقدم حسابات جاريه عاليه
العائد للشركات الناشئه ان الاسبوع الماضي
كان بلا شك الاسبوع الاكبر في تاريخ
الشركه من حيث نمو الودائع حيث شهد راس
المال عشره اضعاف حجم الودائع مقارنه
بالاسبوع الذي سبق بالاضافه الى زياده
مضاعفه في اجمالي قاعده الودائع هذا وتسود
حال من القلق مؤسسي شركات الناشئه بشان
تمكنها من الاستمرار في دفع رواتب
الموظفين بعد فشل از في بي وفيما يخص
العملات المشفره انخفضت ثاني اكبر عمله
مستقره او ستيب الكون من السعر المثبت
بدولار واحد يوم السبت متاثره بتعرض
المصدر سيرك الانترنت فاينانشل لبنك
سيليكون فالي المنهار سعى حمدان العربيه